]
>> GREG: GOOD PEOPLE.
GOOD PEOPLE.
I WISH GOOD PEOPLE WERE HERE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> GREG: HAPPY TUESDAY,
EVERYONE.
IT TURNS OUT, THANKS TO THE
SMASHING SUCCESS OF THIS SHOW,
WHICH HAPPENED BECAUSE OF OUR
AWESOME FANS AND MY RAZOR WI T
AND MY WASH BOARD APES,
ACCORDING TO THE NEWS SITE --
CNN IS REPORTEDLY CONSIDERING
HIRING A COMEDIAN TO HOST ONE OF
ITS PRIMETIME SHOWS.
MAKES SENSE.
THE NETWORK IS STILL A JOKE.
THAT'S MEAN.
APPARENTLY SOME FLOATED NAMES
INCLUDING BILL MAR, TREVOR NOAH
AND JOHN STEWART.
WHAT?
NO ELAINE BOOZLER.
BUT IF THEY WANT COMEDY THEY
SHOULD LAUNCH -- THAT MORE THAN
THE CROW STAPLED TO CHRIS
WALLACE'S.
THEY WENT AHEAD AND RUINED IT.
I'M TALKING, OF COURSE, ABOUT
THE GOLDEN AIMING OF COMEDY.
CHRIS CUOMO, DON LENIN, PERHAPS
AS THEY ARE KNOWN IN THE
BUSINESS, THE THREE STOOGES.
THOSE WERE THE DAYS, RIGHT?
NOW EVERYTHING IS RUINED.
CHRIS LOST HIS KID AFTER TRYING
TO HELP HIS BROTHER ANDREW FEND
OFF A SEXUAL HARASSMENT SCANDAL
WHICH IS LIKE HAVING ALEC
BALDWIN TEACH YOU GUN SAFETY.
HEY, KILL THE LADY.
AND LINEN LOST HIS PRIMETIME GIG
BECAUSE HE COMES OFF AS REAL AS
THIS GUY'S BREASTS.
AND NO OFFENSE TO THAT GUY AND
HIS GIANT FAKE [ BLEEP ] HE'S A
GLOBAL TREASURE.
HE TOOK TIME OFF TO SPEND MORE
TIME WITH HIS HOAGIES.
DID YOU KNOW HE GAVE BLOOD LAST
WEEK?
THAT'S HOW THEY MAKE ALFREDO
SAUCE.
SO DISGUSTING.
[LAUGHTER]
>> GREG: I KNOW, IT'S GROSS.
BUT HOW COULD CNN FORGET THESE
GUYS WERE A RIOT WHEN THEY WERE
TOGETHER.
REMEMBER THIS CLASSIC.
IF YOU WATCH A CERTAIN STATE TV
AND YOU LISTEN TO CONSERVATIVE
MEDIA YOU WOULD THINK, YOU KNOW,
ENTIRE CITIES ARE JUST, YOU
KNOW, BRAWLED IN FIGHTS AND
FIRES AND WHATEVER.
WE WENT OUT FOR A GREAT DINNER
IN NEW YORK CITY.
>> GREG: THE ONLY THING THAT
COULD MAKE THAT FUNNIER IS
BURSTING INTO FLAMES AFTER HE
SAID IT.
I'LL NEVER GET TIRED OF THAT,
AND WHO CAN FORGET THIS.
ONE REASON WHY I'M TAKING YOU
SERIOUSLY AS A CONTENDER IS
BECAUSE OF YOUR PRESENCE ON
CABLE NEWS.
FOR PRESIDENT.
I HEARD A DENTIST USE THIS CLIP
BECAUSE IT'S CHEAPER THAN
LAUGHING GAS.
WHY -- INSTEAD OF PROMOTING IT
IS BONKERS BUT THE THING IS
REGARDLESS OF OUR SHOW'S AMAZING
SUCCESS IF CNN WANTS TO CHASE
COMEDY THEY SHOULD START FIRST
BY BEING REAL.
THAT'S LIKE ASKING SPIELBERG TO
USE A SEQUEL TO SCHINDLER'S LIST
LIKE USING ALVIN AND THE
CHIPMUNKS.
THAT'S BECAUSE COMEDY FOLLOWS
HONESTY AND IF YOU CAN'T BE
TRUTHFUL YOU CAN'T BE FUNNY.
AFTER O.J. SIMPSON'S ACQUITTAL
IN 1995, HE SAID, IT'S FINALLY
OFFICIAL, MURDER IS LEGAL IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THE AUDIENCE ROARED BECAUSE THEY
KNEW IT WAS TRUE BUT THEY ALSO
LAUGHED BECAUSE IN SAYING
SOMETHING YOU GOT THE FEELING HE
SAID SOMETHING HE WASN'T
SUPPOSED TO SAY.
RUMORS SQUIRRELLED THAT THEY
DIDN'T WANT HIM DOING O.J.
JOKES.
HE WAS WILLING TO BREAK THE
RULES TO TELL THE TRUTH.
SO HOW CAN A NETWORK DO THAT
WHILE CALLING MOMS PREGNANT
PEOPLE?
IN ORDER TO BE EFFECTIVE AT
COMEDY YOU HAVE TO RELY ON
TRUTH, NOT IDEOLOGY.
CNN IS SORT OF TRANS -- IN THAT
WAY.
MEANING THEY IDENTIFY AS
TRUTHFUL.
BUT THEY STILL NEVER REALLY MADE
THE CUT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> GREG: REMEMBER WHAT WE REFER
TO AS CNN'S EASTER WHEN CHRIS
CUOMO ROSE FROM THE DEAD, FROM
HIS BASEMENT.
AFTER BEING QUARANTINED WITH
COVID JUST A WEEK AFTER FIGHTING
A CYCLIST.
YOU REMEMBER THIS DURING 2020, A
REPORTER DOES A HIT OUTSIDE A
BURNING BUILDING WHILE ON-SCREEN
CAPTION READS MOSTLY PEACEFUL
PROTESTS.
NOW, THAT'S DISHONESTY, BUT IT'S
HILARIOUS, UNINTENTIONALLY.
WE COULD BE HERE ALL NIGHT
RECITING EXAMPLES FROM CNN'S
PERPETUATION OF THE RUSSIAN
MYTH, TO THEIR 12-HEADED PANELS
OF COCKATOOS TRYING TO OUT --
HYSTERIA.
>> THIS IS WORSE THAN WATERGATE.
>> WORSE THAN WATERGATE.
>> HIS FACE IS WORSE THAN
WATERGATE.
>> BUT ANYWAY, SO BEFORE CNN
ENTERTAINS ANY FANTASIES ABOUT
COMEDY FIRST YOU'VE GOT TO
TACKLE THE TRUTH.
TAKE IT FROM YOUR HUMBLE HOST.
EACH NIGHT WE START FROM THE
RITE AND GO FROM THERE.
WHERE DO WE GO EACH NIGHT?
WHO THE HELL KNOWS.
SOMETIMES IT'S HILARIOUS.
OTHER TIMES IT'S NOT.
REMEMBER THAT WITH COMEDY THE
OUTCOME IS NOT PREDETERMINED.
IT'S WHY WOKE COMEDY CAN'T BE
FUNNY.
THEY ARE NOTHING MORE THAN
SMIRKING DELIVERERS OF BITTER
LECTURES AND IT'S A TALE THAT
THEY REQUIRE YOU TO AGREE RATHER
THAN LAUGH AND THAT'S BECAUSE
THERE IS NO EQUITY IN LAUGHTER.
YOU EITHER LAUGH OR YOU DON'T.
TRY TO ESTABLISH A QUOTA AND
YOU'LL BE THE JOKE.
LET'S --
[APPLAUSE]
>> GREG: WELCOME TONIGHT'S
GUEST.
SHE'S KNOWN FOR HER CHEERLEADING
AND LEAVING YOUR EARS BLEEDING.
CO-HOST --
[APPLAUSE]
>> GREG: HIS COMEDY IS SO DARK
EVERY TICKET TO HIS SHOW COMES
WITH A FREE HEAD LAMP.
COMEDIAN KIRK --
[APPLAUSE]
>> GREG: HE DRESSES LIKE A
MAGICIAN BECAUSE HE CAN MAKE
LAUGHTER DISAPPEAR.
HOST OF FOX ACROSS AMERICA,
JIMMY FALLON.
[APPLAUSE]
>> GREG: AND SHE'S NEVER BEEN
TOLD THAT SHE LIGHTS UP A ROOM.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT --
[APPLAUSE]
>> GREG: A LITTLE TRIVIA HERE
ABOUT KIRK METZGER.
I BELIEVE HE WAS ON THE ORIGINAL
PANEL ON THE GUTFELD SHOW WHEN
WE HAD THE TALKING WALL.
>> I WAS A PUPPETEER AND WRITER
ON THE SHOW.
I WAS NOT PAID FOR EAST OF
THOSE.
>> GREG: YOU WERE NOT PAID.
IT'S NOT ON YOUR C.V., YOU DON'T
BRAG ABOUT IT.
I UNDERSTAND.
DO YOU HAVE ANY COMEDY ADVICE
FOR CNN?
>> WELL, THE NAMES THEY FLOATED,
I GUESS THE LAST NAMES, LET'S
SAY YOU LAND GREAT HOST, YOU GET
LIKE A TREVOR -- A GUY WITH A
PERFECTLY ROUND HEAD.
>> GREG: YES.
>> YOU HAVE THAT IT'S A MATTER
OF WHAT WRITERS ARE YOU GOING TO
GET.
I DON'T KNOW IF PEOPLE THINK THE
HOSTS WRITE THE JOKES BUT THEY
DON'T AND WHERE ARE YOU GOING TO
FIND ALL THE TRANSWRITERS OF
COLOR TO FILL THE COMEDY?
YOU HAVEN'T GOTTEN THE
TRANSQUEER WRITERS YET.
>> GREG: WHY ARE YOU COUNTING
YOURSELF OUT, IF YOU IDENTIFY --
WHAT DO YOU IDENTIFY AS THESE
DAYS.
>> IT'S FLUID.
>> GREG: GENDER FLUID?
>> I'M ABLE FLUID, I WOULD CALL
IT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> I HURT MY BACK RECENTLY.
>> GREG: SO YOU'RE GENDER FLUID
AND YOU MIGHT BE HANDICAPPED.
>> YES.
>> GREG: I THINK YOU'VE GOT A
GIG.
YOU JUST GOT PROMOTED.
YOU'RE DISABLED.
>> THAT'S A HOME GAME FOR THE
CHAMP.
[APPLAUSE]
>> DO YOU WORK WITH TIGERS?
>> GREG: AM I TIGER KING?
FROM MY CAROL BASKIN COLLECTION.
IT'S SO FUNNY.
WHAT DO YOU GAIN FROM THIS
STORY.
THIS ISN'T ABOUT BLOWING OUR OWN
HORN.
IT'S ALL OVER THE PLACE NOW.
>> FIRST OF ALL IT'S KIND OF
HILARIOUS THAT EVERY NETWORK
WANTS TO WALK A MILE IN THEIR
SHOES BUT THEY CAN'T BECAUSE
THEY ARE A SIZE THREE.
I OWED YOU ONE.
I HAVE ANGLES HERE.
THE FIRST ONE IS THAT THEY ARE
SAYING THEY ARE GOING DOWN THIS
ROUTE BECAUSE THEY PRODUCED --
LET'S JUST GET IT OUT OF THE WAY
BUT THE POINT YOU GUYS BOTH MADE
AND IT'S THE REASON THEY HAVE
CRIPPLED LATE NIGHT COMEDY, IS
BECAUSE WHEN YOU GO WOKE YOU
TAKE ALL THE TARGETS OFF THE
TABLE.
YOU HAVE RULES ABOUT PUNCHING UP
INSTEAD OF PUNCHING DOWN AND
YOU'VE GOT TO LEAVE THE ROOM
AND -- THE DEMOCRATS, BY TAKING
THE FUN OUT OF THEIR PARTY
SCREWED DID COMEDIANS THAT KIND
OF GRAVITATED TOWARD THEIR
PARTY.
I'LL GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE.
LAST WEEK THE DEMOCRATS VOTED
AGAINST ALLOWING CIGARS INSIDE
THE CAPITOL.
20 YEARS AGO THEY WERE FINE WITH
CIGARS INSIDE INTERNS.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
[APPLAUSE]
>> YOU WENT A LONG WAY FOR THAT.
>> GREG: LISTEN, WE HAVE TIME
BETWEEN TAKES ON TIGER KING.
WE CAN DIG IN.
>> I LOVE THE FACT THAT ONE OF
THE NETWORK SOURCES SAID THEY
ARE LOOKING FOR THEIR JOHN
OLIVER.
AREN'T THEY ALL JOHN OLIVERS?
AREN'T THEY ALL THE SAIL VERSION
OF JOHN OLIVER?
MY GOD.
>> THAT'S SO FUNNY.
>> GREG: EMILY, WELCOME TO THE
SHOW.
>> THANKS.
>> GREG: DO YOU HAVE ANYTHING
INTERESTING TO ADD TO THIS
CONVERSATION.
>> NO MATTER WHAT HAPPENS, CNN
IS STILL CNN.
IT'S LIKE EVERY 1980s MOVIE,
WHOLE PLOT IS SOMEONE TRYING TO
BE SOMEONE THEY AREN'T, RIGHT?
THE END OF GRIEF.
YOU CAN'T BE THE PERSON THAT
YOU'RE NOT.
THE NERD CAN'T BE THE HAWK GIRL,
WHATEVER IT IS, ALTHOUGH SOME OF
THEM CAN FOR A SECOND BUT THE
POINT IS NO MATTER WHAT HAPPENS
TO CNN THEY ARE ALWAYS GOING TO
REVERT BACK BECAUSE THEY ARE
LOOKING FOR JOHN OLIVER.
WHAT THEY ARE TRYING TO FIND IS
THEIR OWN YOU AND THAT'S NEVER
GOING TO HAPPEN.
>> GREG: THAT'S SUCH A NICE
THING TO SAY.
>> DON'T MAKE HIS EGO ANY
BIGGER.
>> THEY ARE LOOKING FOR JOHN
OLIVER BUT WHAT THEY REALLY
NEEDED WAS YOU.
[LAUGHTER]
>> GREG: WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK.
>> FLIP SAID HE PUT OUT AN EMAIL
AND SAID YOU GUYS MAY NOT LIKE
THIS.
YOU MAY BE CONFUSED HE SAID IN
AN EMAIL TO EVERYONE BUT I'M
TRYING TO HAVE RATIONAL
CONVERSATIONS AROUND POLARIZING
TOPICS SO YOU'RE GOING TO TRY TO
BE FOX.
JUST HAVE NORMAL CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT TOPICS THAT PEOPLE FEEL
HEATED ABOUT.
THAT'S INCENDIARY.
ACCORDING TO KEITH OLBERMANN,
HE'S CALLED THEM A FASCIST
BECAUSE OF IT.
HEAVEN HELP THE FACT THAT
FINALLY TWO YEARS AFTER EXPOSING
HIMSELF IN FRONT OF THE ENTIRE
COMPANY, JEFFREY WAS ACTUALLY
CALLING SO ARE THEY MAKING SMALL
STRIDES?
>> THAT WAS THE BIGGEST JOKE OF
THEM ALL.
>> AT THE END OF THE DAY A TIGER
CAN'T REMOVE ITS STRIPES AND CNN
CAN'T DEPART FROM THE FACT THAT
THEY ARE AT THE END OF THE DAY
THE JOKE THEMSELVES.
[APPLAUSE]
>> GREG: I THOUGHT THEY WERE
GOING TO GO BACK TO COVERING
STRAIGHT NEWS BUT NOW THEY ARE
LOOKING AT US AND GOING WHAT ARE
THEY DOING OVER THERE?
WE NEED A KAT OF THEIR OWN.
>> I JUST LOVE THAT THIS COUNTS
AS AN IDEAS, LIKE, THEY ARE
DOING A COMEDY, AND IT'S GOING
WELL, SO WE SHOULD ALSO DO A
COMEDY.
I WANT TO BE AN EXECUTIVE.
IF THAT'S WHAT COUNTS AS
CONTRIBUTING SOMETHING TO A
CONVERSATION.
>> GREG: THAT'S ALL YOU HAVE TO
DO.
>> THEY DIDN'T SAY HOW WOULD IT
BE DIFFERENT OR UNIQUE OR
SOMETHING THAT'S ALREADY OUT
THERE?
THIS OTHER THING IS GOOD SO WE
SHOULD ALSO HAVE OUR OWN GOOD
THING.
AND THAT ACTUALLY GETS REPORTED
ON, THAT'S AN ACTUAL DISCUSSION.
OBVIOUSLY, THIS SHOW, THERE IS
NOTHING ELSE LIKE THIS SHOW,
WHETHER YOU LIKE IT OR YOU DON'T
LIKE IT.
THERE ISN'T ANYTHING ELSE LIKE
IT SO HOW WOULD THEIRS BE
DIFFERENT?
THEY HAVE NOT DISCUSSED THAT,
WHICH AGAIN, I WANT TO BE A
C.E.O.
>> WHY IS CNN TALKING ABOUT THIS
AND NOT LIKE THE NETWORKS WITH
COMEDY?
WE SHOULD DO A COMEDY HERE.
>> GREG: COMEDY CENTRAL SHOULD
GO, WE SHOULD START DOING
COMEDY.
[LAUGHTER]
>> GREG: YOU'RE RIGHT.
IT IS FUNNY.
THE WHOLE THING IS FLIPPED AND
IT'S FOX.
YOU KNOW, YOU THINK RIGHT WING.
YOU THINK EVERY STEREOTYPE THAT
GOES WITH IT, AND YET, LIKE,
WE'RE THE ONLY PERSON DOING --
WHAT'S BASICALLY LIKE A ROUGH
CROWD TYPE SHOW WHERE --
>> LIKE THE APOCALYPSE.
>> GREG: I MIGHT BE SATAN.
I DO DRI